[Music]
which
well hello they are watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive time to see
what's making the headlines with
uh the conservative commentator tim
montgomery and i was going to say the
contributing editor to navarro media
moyer lothian mclean but she's not here
yet tim it's down to you for the moment
so we're standby no poor viewers
uh front pages there let's start then
shall we the metro has word of
heartbreak for archie's family as the 12
year old's life support is due to be
switched off tomorrow
the times leading with a poll saying
that 66 of tory party members prefer liz
trust as the next leader and prime
minister
the telegraph reports that voting has
been delayed because of a cyber threat
to the election process
the express interviews liz truss who
says she's the only candidate who can
deliver the growth britain needs
the financial times leads with the u.s
house speaker nancy pelosi touching down
in taiwan prompting the chinese
government to conduct military drills
the mail also leads on the threat from
china in response
while the eye criticizes the department
for education for not guaranteeing girls
equal access to football in pe lessons
even after the lionesses triumph at the
weekend
reporting that bp has made seven billion
pounds in the last three months amidst
the energy crisis the mirror brands them
brazen profiteers
and that is also the lead story for the
guardian there outrage they say as oil
firms rake in huge profits while bills
saw
well a reminder by scanning the qr code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out those front pages
while you watch us or tim
unless she's here oh this she's here
moyer loading mclean joins us as well
moya great to have you with us as well
and let's kick off with you in fact and
uh just start with the metro um the
newspaper that's leading uh with the the
terrible plight and anguish um of archie
battersby's family with the with the
news for them and an awful day ahead of
them tomorrow
yes so this is the news that archibald's
family who have campaigned for months to
keep him on life support um that they've
been told their appeals have failed that
he will be taken off life support at 11
a.m on wednesday
they are mounting a last-ditch legal
attempt at the european court of human
rights um but in lieu of that they've
also asked for archie to if he is going
to be taken of life support they want
him moved to a hospice they say they
want him to
die
peacefully and surrounded by family um
but there's no news here on whether that
will even be possible i think this case
has been a particularly harrowing one
for parents across the country
um it's been really distressing to see
the family's pain play out in front of
us
but what it has
been in terms of a legal precedent as
it's shown how important it is for those
roots of appeal and those roots to the
you know strasbourg and the european
court of human rights um are for people
when they're pursuing cases like this
and they you know his mother
holly holly um dance has said she'll
pursue every last possible legal action
and it's shown how key it is to have
those channels for people to do this and
keep that hope alive
yeah there was a lengthy statement
certainly um at the supreme court today
you know the judges pointing out um that
the issue is not about archie's recovery
but about the timing and manner of his
death and and they said even if
life-sustaining treatment were to be
maintained archer would die in the
course of the next few weeks through
organ failure and then heart failure um
and obviously tim
um the central part of the law of
england and wales is that the child's
interests come first and and that is
what the law is dictating here in fact
look
i have i think i'm sure for all three of
us here tonight you know our heart goes
out to everyone involved in this case
there's a picture i think in the time
today it was probably in other
newspapers
of archie in his bed with a little
cuddly bunny rabbit you know his side
which obviously was a you know a
childhood toy this is
yeah
even even talking about it now um you
know
one chokes up and
everyone here the courts the the the
doctors it's tough for all of them but
my general view is we should err on the
side of patients the the parents that
the love of a parent for their children
is the greatest force for good in my
view in a in a society and i think some
of the basic requests of the parents you
know even now wanting to take their son
out of the
chaos and the noise of a hospital so
that he might die in a hospice's is is
being refused and this just seems to me
to be just a little bit too harsh at the
end i i don't want to criticize anyone
involved in this because it is
nightmarish but
just giving that little bit more of the
balance of doubt to the parents at this
time is what i would have hoped to have
seen but as moya says that the courts
have gone to the highest level now
certainly within the uk there has been a
proper process of appeal and so i i
hesitate to make an alternative judgment
but personally i don't think we are
quite as uh
erring on the side of parents as i think
um we should
yes it's hard to you know to get past
that beautiful child's face isn't it in
all of those pictures we saw there
certainly and as you said we extend our
sympathies to all his family and
everybody who knew him it's a very very
difficult uh um you know story to deal
with for everybody i think certainly um
let's head on to the conservative
leadership contest um tim i know you're
aware about this i'm going to kick off
with you
everybody wondering where their ballot
papers were well it turns out according
to the telegraph that gchq has got
involved and they have said that cyber
hackers could change people's ballots um
tell us more
well this is a breaking story for me
anna as well so i don't want to say
too much about it but one thing i am
wondering about was there was this
curious innovation in this election
whereby if a tory member such as myself
voted now for one candidate there was
the possibility that we could change our
vote later in the process electronically
now we can't do that in any other you
know normal election and that made me
worry about you know the the the sort of
the rigor the robustness of this system
anyway and perhaps other people have
thought um there's an opportunity here
and we know that powers like russia have
tried to intervene in elections before
this isn't just the election of the
conservative party leader this is the
election of the prime minister of the
united kingdom so i am encouraged that
there's been a delay even if the risk is
only small that the security services
are involved and they're investigating
to ensure that this process cannot be
contaminated and cannot be infiltrated
but i think until we've seen the detail
of the story and i haven't yet i've
emailed and texted a few
key contacts tonight haven't heard back
from them yet but obviously we cannot
have a system which will choose boris
johnson's successor open to any kind of
abuse by economic interest who might be
trying to spook or alter betting markets
or much more seriously a foreign power
that is trying to for example you know
potentially change the person who'll be
deciding policy on ukraine and other key
things in the in the weeks ahead well
tim we have had a site of one of the
letters being sent to
the voting tory members
it says your ballot is on the way thank
you so much for your patience uh as we
have worked to put this election
together
it will arrive with you a little later
than we originally said please do not
worry this is because we have taken some
time to add some additional security to
our ballot process which has delayed us
slightly and then goes on to say it is
an offence to vote more than once etc
etc so acknowledgement there that there
is a delay uh and the uh the telegraph
with the with that story in the meantime
moya the times um tells us that rishi
sunank is actually falling well behind
they've carried out a poll with yougov
um which says that uh rishi sunak has 26
of the vote as it stands uh well liz
trust has 60 percent of the vote a 34
point lead does she look um unassailable
do you think
i mean
it's funny we talk about nefarious
actors within uh the tory voting contest
there are only two options so we have to
wonder if anyone was trying to influence
the vote who would they actually be
influencing the vote in favour of um so
yes this is a new poll by yougov which
seems to suggest that it's very recent
that seems to suggest despite liz
truss's
interesting policy announcements over
the last few days her very public u-turn
on what is being called the public
sector tax um that she will storm it she
is much more popular apparently with the
polled conservative members than rishi
sunak it found that
early voting will also benefit liz trust
um six percent of members said that they
would vote for her over sunak and it
said that 45 of members who were
questioned would vote as soon as they
received their ballot papers um and it
found that liz trust outstripped russia
sumac in terms of being seen as more in
touch with ordinary people they thought
she was more likeable they thought she
was more trustworthy um however
supporters of rishi zunak have hit back
at this polling and said that it's
notoriously difficult to accurately
sample toy members opinions um which at
this stage of the competition
looks a bit like limpy trying to hold
back the oncoming tide of trust but we
will wait and see and as tim pointed out
there was this strange innovation where
potentially members can change their
votes within the next two months but as
it stands it seems like liz trust may
well be the next prime minister of the
uk yeah and certainly that change
change your vote ability was seen as a
boost to rishi sunak because liz trust
had the early lead but that seems to be
being established more doesn't it
comment on that and also what did you
call it a public sector to pay tax what
did you call it what
i called a public sector pay tax but
that is accurate it was her it was her
plan that it was it was more about
regional payloads it's that across the
country people would have public sector
workers would have their pay changed in
line with the regional living costs
which of course would mean an effective
pay cut for millions of workers in
regions outside of london in the middle
of a cost of living crisis yes so this
idea of regional pay awards makes the
top of the front page of the eye the
inside pages of the mirror as well tim
you know is it damaging for her does she
believe in this idea of regional pay
what does that mean to leveling up
stroke leveling down and you know if if
she's throwing out all these policies
all the time will some of them fall flat
well there's so much there for me to
come back on but look rishi's campaign
wishes tonight's campaign is in big
trouble now this is a massive lead for
liz trust amongst um conservative
members on another channel yesterday i
promise to come and eat my hat or
whatever if liz plus isn't prime
minister at the end of um september at
the beginning of september excuse me and
but she has had about 24 hours she
announced this policy and for the
reasons moira has just sort of suggested
the idea that you're going to level down
public sector pay rather than level up
public sector pay you know it's
frightened uh people and uh she's made a
terrible policy choice but unlike for
example theresa may or others in the
past who stuck with policies they
shouldn't have done you know she's
u-turned very quickly said i think the
damage is perhaps minimized although
there will be questions now about her
judgment uh because of this um u-turn
but one thing about that opinion poll
that you know that gives um rishi sunak
a commanding lead on the front page of
tomorrow's times the polling was
conducted over the last five days so it
won't really be included the effect of
um
liz trust's worst day of the campaign so
yes rishi sunak is in trouble but the
delay to the ballot papers that we've
just been discussing because of security
concerns and liz trust is awkward 24
hours will perhaps give
the sunac campaign a glimmer of hope
which i think actually will
not come to very much but we'll give
them a glimmer of hope that they can
still turn this round yes although the
times um hugo polda suggests that uh
most of them have made their minds up
already but as you say it's changeable
is it not
i will keep an eye on that story moving
on though uh we will go to bp which has
made seven billion pounds in three
months as the energy crisis continues
more on that in just a moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now my login
mclean and tim montgomery welcome back
to both of you um so another energy
giant makes big profits um moya
yes this is bp who've recorded their
biggest quarterly profit in 14 years if
you're a shareholder and bp great news
for you you're going to get four billion
pounds um overall in dividends however
for those people on the ground such as
you or i our energy bills are predicted
to be more than three thousand six
hundred by october there's another rise
in the so-called price cap by 70
and now people are starting to say there
needs to be action taken the tax breaks
that were given to these energy
companies are being questioned by the
likes of labor and people are calling
for an instant tax on their profits
given they've skyrocketed so much
including martin lewis famed social
campaigner now has been supporting
bringing in a social tariff which would
give potentially low-income households a
1 000 discount on their energy costs
this year
we've we've rehearsed these arguments
last week haven't we you know these are
global profits et cetera et cetera but
i'm going to move on if you don't mind
we're quite sure of time but uh no doubt
we'll come back to that um to the news
uh front page of the financial times
this controversial visit by nancy pelosi
speaker of the u.s house of
representatives uh in taiwan china not
happy tim
no not happy and i'm generally with
nancy pelosi i'm on the opposite side of
politics to nancy pelosi i normally
disagree with her
on everything but my goodness i really
salute what she's done
here china likes to intimidate everyone
it thinks that just by saying there will
be repercussions we'll all count out
them we certainly i think failed as a
western civilization to stand up for the
ouija muslims adequately enough in the
persecution camps in china failed to
stand up enough to the rolling back of
democratic freedoms in hong kong and we
must now stand with the free people of
taiwan and so nancy pelosi going there
in this high-profile way despite all the
pressure would put upon her is
absolutely vital especially in the
context of the russia's invasion of
ukraine we must make it clear to these
totalitarian powers that we will stand
with democracy
and i'm just reading that the guardian
is reporting that china's uk ambassador
has vowed severe consequences if british
politicians visit taiwan so uh we'll see
where that takes us both of you thank
you very much indeed moya tim thank you